ce qui est très
embrayage
Même les montagnes dorment, Kampung Gunung Pong Pong
Pong Pong Pong Pong Pong Pong Pong Pong Pong
Pong Pong Pong déjà
des produits
Travail
Odong-odong
odong-odong odong-odong
plus de pompons de pocong jurent des crimes
la femme la plus méchante la plus probable Boom
Boum plus
Odong-odong
thé avec
tajweed ul kelong
Le gros camion de Binahong ne sait pas quoi dire
Vous savez
Toi
accompli
mentir
Salut Jokowi
Abi Bi Eha
demeure dans Salut les amis et
Engkong Engkong Engkong Engkong
papillon Hé
Il ne pleut pas sur Genza Bop
au revoir
HY frère
heureux
Hussein
au revoir
Ruri
whg peut a.ma
Salut Kismat
revenu très rapide
même
soi-disant Pong Pong Pong
Pong-Pong-Pong
Pong-Pong-Pong-Pong
pouah ouais fou euh euh